bonjour
[Musique]
et
notre porte
les airs
une industrie alt quoi
va se braquer
qu'ils en europe
d
là on va parier là tout de suite on va
lui avait donc on va passer là pour la
chaume
et
[Musique]
on
le soleil se lève ou regarder que nous
mêmes
[Musique]
ranger la tranche matane godard en
accroissant
je pense
[Musique]
comprendre les cartes c'est comprendre
des sables d'olonne aujourd'hui une
ville qui est divisé en deux parties
bien distinctes
la chaux d'un côté les sables d'olonne
de l'autre avec entre les deux et bien
le port et puis surtout le chenal et qui
a quelque part coupé la ville en deux
aujourd'hui encore échu au moins
l'habitude de dire qu'ils ont mis leur
avance sur les sables bah c'est pas
complètement faux si on regarde la
géographie puisque la ville des sables
et bien à une certaine époque n'existait
pas dire que entre la chaume et puis la
plage de tanchet tu es bien vous aviez
ce qu'on appelait le havre d'olonne donc
c'était un grand couloir un bras de mer
qui remontaient lui aussi jusqu'à brem
sur mer et petit à petit sur ce bras de
mer s'est fixé du sable de la dune qu'on
voit ici
et bien sûr cette dune et bien une
population s'est fixé et cette
population a donné naissance aux sables
d'olonne
[Musique]
on connaître pour qu'on aime le remblai
solitaire pour ce pôle est en fait très
sincèrement la station elle s'ouvre elle
s'offre en fait aux promeneurs
[Musique]
voilà
je requiers manuelles jeux les
machines-outils des sols patrimoine la
mer les gens ont envie de repartir et
quelques temps j quand on regarde les
stats sont arabes trottoir c'est
vraiment des stades de rapports qui
explique comment les propriétaires pour
rapporter un peu d'argent de cette manne
qui représentait d'un mode de la
villégiature se replie youn était dans
ses sous-sols et loup et donc les
parties hautes des parties nobles aux
baigneurs qui venaient profiter de la
mer
[Musique]
oh
non
[Musique]
bon
là je viens de recevoir une vieille
carte postale de la maison 10 l'hectare
[Musique]
et
dilecta c'est une référence latine qui
attire très cher donc qu'il a supposé
que propriétaire à penser cette maison
en référence à son épouse sera
certainement
oui le pas de tir
[Musique]
c'est un détail
complètement atypique j'ai jamais eu ça
ne ment pas
[Musique]
dilecta ma chérie cette estrade
magnifique pour la faire chanter
voilà à ressasser les belles trouvailles
juste
[Musique]
google
c
[Musique]
ces techniques pour arriver à la chose
sassus il va tout seul
je
pourquoi les irriter comme astérix
rapport comme le village de balle et on
va continuer en janvier comme sur la
guitare
et pourquoi ça s'appelle de bar du
prophète il aboie révoltant mais il est
là bas où il est né
la cil bar du pont le chevoir considère
ce jour pendant un jour de deuil du jour
au lendemain on leur a passé 2 rebonds
et sans les prévenir
on savait que le poil est détruit mais
on avait caché volontairement à la
population locale la date de destruction
si on avait pu voir que des voilà que
des
des cheveux noirs récalcitrants se
mettre sur le pont et empêcher la
destruction donc lavées il avait avait
étouffé la sphère avait étouffé la date
de la destruction et les chemins l'eau
très mal pris parce qu'ils se sont
réveillés le matin du 7 novembre a bien
devant le fait accompli ils avaient plus
de ponts et sens pont voilà la chaume et
est complètement isolée du reste du
monde
alors on dit souvent que la chaume c'est
un petit peu un repaire de flibustiers
ou un petit peu comme le village
d'astérix et obélix
mais dans l'âme c'est un petit peu ça
dans l'esprit c'est encore ensuite le
sac là on se dirige chez lian d'illac
rabote féminin figure chaunoise une des
dernières femmes à au franc-parler et
diane ses moyens bonjour à toi j'ai
dérangé enfants c'est pas grave
au contraire j'étais pourra les
vêtements les je suis je te suivre alors
que je suis je suis je te suivrai
premier rang non pas du tout j'ai donné
un coup de main
par la même occasion c'est plus jamais
un hub ayant coulé en l'air et
jacquouille j'ai remonté il se dévoile
on peut chanter au mans ils sont bons je
remets du nice qui est sec
on peut dire que t'as pas vécu au sable
c'est un peu ça la cheminée finale à la
chaux opérette rapport au pari du sable
non non je suis une chaunoise donc la
chose c'est un village quoi donc nous
les shows move pour que nous disent
qu'on est sablais
alors dites et mais oui mais chez moi
sinon je suis pas le sable est une vraie
joie
[Musique]
pour nick ses notes nangon voilà le la
gauche aux moines
dans le caza france y est je vous voulez
venir nous sommes là n'est pas là
puisque vous allez vous dégagez las
alors il ya déjà des gens qui tard parce
qu'on parle de trop on vient et c'est
pour ça qu'elle a de pire est qu'il y en
a d'autres qui restent parce qu'ils sont
contents d'entendre tous nos
commentaires quand tu vois moi j'arrive
à leur idole je laissais fini landou
plus ici on vient pas ici pour dormir
mais c'est vrai que nous ça sort comme
ça quoi hein quand même faire attention
où on se trouve avec qui il faut les
petits vont sur des clubs ont fait des
efforts on essaye essaye de faire des
mais c'est toujours facile parce que ça
revient degré soins la shoah c'est une
brune tous ceux qui la connaissent
grisé à ses caresses à la presse que
salomon les reviennent toujours
la chaux à ces âmes où chaque scène
super sera plus facile en montant web et
en montant c'est plus facile tu vas voir
le plaisir du golfe le plaisir d'un
petit village de pêcheurs et le plaisir
d'y être
[Musique]
c'est tellement spécial qu' il faut
s'intégrer à la chaume et puis c'est la
vraie vie il faut participer à tous il
faut participer aux fêtes il faut
participer aux animations
voilà c'est fondamental et puis surtout
le quai ne pas oublier le quai faut
aller sur lequel si on ne va pas sur le
quai on ne vit pas le choix
[Musique]
moi
c'est très grave
[Musique]
tiens salut ça va
alors
déjà 8 mai david david maubert devient
rien
tous les matins je fais mon petit tour
je vais avoir les balais copains et puis
voir un petit peu ce qui se fait dans la
nuit s'il ya du monde dehors et super
offre
je vais apprendre un peu la température
deux vaches au fond
ça
et elles doivent être contents
[Musique]
aujourd'hui au niveau valeur marchande
il c'est une des pluies avec les ventes
de prix les plus élevés quoi donc il
vient des bateaux de bretagne lorient
concarneau quimper enfin il vient
vraiment du monde mais là on est en
début du début de saison quoi mais iliad
acclament puis à priori surtout un bon
prix et ça c'est bien
[Musique]
ouais bon journal
ouais
il arrive
guillaume le camion il n'a pas bougé
depuis hier il est tout près ben écoute
on peut venir tout de suite ils ont un
problème avec la fermeture de la porte
écluse il pense qu'il ya un pneu il ya
quelque chose qui les fait chier je vais
on va y aller ouais ali
rien n'a bougé depuis hier soir
hausse mardi
la chose la capitale de la france
voilà tagué recul et wasquehal
[Musique]
la banque dit avoir dedans
ouais je pense que c'est super tu dois
tu l'as tu la verrouiller puis bas le
temps qu'on s'équipe sa frappe le voile
[Musique]
vous
le
m
[Musique]
il y en a qui rentrent dans le port aux
sables à cause de service parce qu'ils
savent qu'il ya des plongeurs 24 sur 24
savent bien
à calais
m
oh
on va les laisser passer peut-être pas
d'accord c'est les mecs al ahram tout
seul surtout bien les bateaux en bois on
va les laisser passer au cran derrière
[Musique]
il ya une mentalité qui est ordinaire et
les gens sont extraordinaires ici la
gauche beaucoup et un très très bon état
d'esprit on le voit bien pour la fête ça
moi ça me ferait dire un peu comme le
vendée globe voyez il ya une animation
mais les quais sont plaints du début
jusqu'à la fin
ça c'est le grand bonheur quoi voilà
pour tout le monde c'est sympa que les
gens se déplacent
[Musique]
vous
encore plus
[Musique]
le programme art et de marron